today is Memorial Day it is a day to
remember sacrifice it also marks the
unofficial start of summer and in these
trying times that means a chance for
people to recapture their normal lives
by visiting the beach and it's also a
big test for social distancing the
holiday led the scenes like this one in
Galveston Texas where the beach was
crowded and masks were far were few and
far between rather Don Dahler is at the
New Jersey Shore in Seaside Heights New
Jersey Don good morning what's it been
like there hey good morning I'm sure
you've brought Teddy here this of course
is the boardwalk the amusement park
right now at Seaside Heights is still
closed under these restrictions and all
up and down Jersey Shore this weekend
the crowds have been relatively sparse
now that might be because the weather
has been somewhat underwhelming and with
the chances of it barely making into the
60s today we can expect to see more of
the same but across the nation it's been
a real mix of people who have been
willing to social distance and those who
haven't in Indiana near Chicago and the
Illinois border people waited for hours
to get on the sand at Porter Beach and
as you can see masks were scarce this is
a jam-packed pool party at Lake of the
Ozarks in Missouri not only are people
shoulder-to-shoulder once again masks
were practically non-existent it comes
as a second Missouri hairstylist that
worked at this great clips in
Springfield has tested positive for the
corona virus officials say she worked
while experiencing symptoms and
potentially exposed 56 clients that's on
top of 84 people who came in contact
with another stylist he was also
infected and of course we should remind
people that you can have this virus and
be asymptomatic not show symptoms you're
feeling great you're having fun with
people but you can still get other
people infected so time will tell
whether these groups that we've been
describing to you and showing you
pictures of it and groups that we
haven't are going to lead to a spike in
more kovin 19 cases Anthony all right
Don Dahler Thank You Don